yo what's up guys this is prestige here
again and today
well for one you might notice that but
today we're gonna go on an adventure
and this adventure means we are going to
leave everything we once held dear
i have recently because uh because we
didn't have the
heroin mod uh a disclaimer you're not
gonna see her burn in this video in the
past like every single video i've said
the mod hasn't been working
but it's still i'm just gonna name these
hair brand experience
because i do have faith that one day the
mod will return but i
implemented a bunch of new mods and the
biggest one uh one called auto switcher
one
yeah biggest one i'd say is
one called gems plus which adds
like 15-ish new oars and stuff to the
game
now we're gonna we're gonna start on the
journey i scouted out some land
and on the way i'll explain why we have
to go so this we're saying goodbye to
that house i'm leaving it up but we're
saying goodbye so goodbye
now the reason i started out some land
and i went into creative mode and i flew
around and i found some lane and that's
how i found my first plot
patch of land so if you're against that
then i'm sorry but that's how i route
now the reason we're leaving i told you
we had the gems mod and
adds new ores but they only spawn
in new unloaded chunks like if i already
have loaded chunk it that
doesn't it can't put the oars into the
chunk because it's already loaded
everything's already there and i've
explored
decently a good around my house decently
like a good amount around my house
i've explored that to a decent amount
so i flew found some new land made sure
the oars were there
and that is where where we are headed
you can see don't worry i didn't forget
all my goods i brought in all the goods
that uh were more valuable
and euro show we're going to be
continuing
and we're going to build a house and
we're going to chill there
and so yeah it's going to be the new
stuff hopefully i won't have any more
mods that
require new chunks so we won't need to
bail on our home anymore
because i know you can get it very
attached to a home now we're at negative
300 500
it was at negative 6 15
7.50 so we're going through iron i don't
have any space for it
you see my inventory is completely full
probably going to drop the shuffle but
whatever
now it's past this
yeah once i pass this tiger i should be
at the spot
on the great journey to the new homeland
but up some smooth lightning errors
right there
am i getting held up i want to check
some video sentences smooth lighting
bring down a little more since smooth
lighting i'd say is the biggest
lagger and the fact that i'm recording
makes a lag
and my computer isn't like some super
computer it's just an average desktop
that's kind of that's i wouldn't say old
it's old in terms
of that every single year
the computers get like 3 000 times the
better
so it's all in that sense but and it's
like five years or something
something like that now we're in the
forest so the house that i found is in
this forest
not house but uh just location that i
want to live
and i set up in honor of good friday
since it is good friday today for those
of you that
do not know um
if you're not christian i'm i'm
christian so
that's i celebrate good friday
uh well a lot of people wouldn't know
even if they're not a christian because
it's just a big holiday but
okay this is the lake that i found
that's awesome okay there there it is
there's a cross
uh this sunday is gonna be easter for
the
everybody except the orthodox since they
have a different easter
i go and yeah
so today is the day that jeez the
day we honor as the day jesus died in
the cross
and so i made a little cross emblem to
signify that uh that's also just
to find my way back to this area now
i'm gonna break that down he kept it
first
so yeah this i was i wanted to record
for a long time
and just split the videos up so
that would be cool if i could do that
except i know this mic
sometimes just goes crazy and just
like it starts making my voice talk
roboticky
so that sucks so i was thinking
i could put the house in this
little nugget right here i'd obviously
do a lot of land cleanering
but make a base house right around here
and then break down all these trees in
the way
for so i could see this lake front
property
yeah so i think i'll get to that
and probably want to stop destroying
stuff with my sword
so first things first make that
make that crafting table three on the
ground for a sec
crafting table one two
um yeah i'm gonna have enough boop boop
chest
throw on all the stuff i don't need for
building
let's see i'm gonna need that to make a
bed
do not need any of these
i'm gonna want a little bit of food and
we have enough wood so
okay i'm gonna kill you okay so good out
cow
oh yeah another mod i got was uh the
auto switch mod
which like you say i'm going to hit the
dirt it's which is why i need i want
your shovel
uh say will out it switch it to shovel
and back
if you guys ever want me to do a mod
review on all this stuff mods i got then
i'd be happy to
but i also i had one more mod the
tornado mod but i took that out because
i feel like it was causing me lag
but i really don't think it was yeah
i don't know well let's get cooking on
this house
boom boom boom oh i can
throw these seeds in there all right now
i'm not sure how i want to do this
maybe just like there
say from there
to there to there and to
there and the other block will be right
there
you gotta be good hmm i think i'd be
good
yeah boom boom
boom boom all right now i'm thinking
what should i do though
should i like make it out of wood
well i want some glass and get some
glass going to start cooking it
should that probably shouldn't be that
big of a priority for me but
i want some glass so we're gonna push
this
beach front property back a bit
there we go all the water's even nice 18
sand uh let's get a little more
let's get one more line of it just we're
just good on sand
uh 4610 that should be good
sorry i just thought this was a pretty
cool place and
yeah so we're just going to need to get
situated again and then we can start
adventuring
so i'm going to make a furnace
i left most of the stuff uh utilities at
my whole house just just
for sentimental purposes
and i'm gonna want this coal i'm gonna
want to throw
half of you in there no
half and boom boom
now to disrupt within the house should i
just do like
you think this is good
i think i could make the corners
oak wood like logs
that'd be cool i think i'll do that
i need an axe right i have an axe
so iron we're gonna want and that's
enough iron
i left my axes practically destroyed so
new axe that'll be good
and one eh
two tree oh it's getting nighttime okay
we're gonna want to go
faster
should i make any of this out of
birchwood i don't know
okay well we want the we have the wool
and we're going to go boom
and we're gonna make ourselves a bed
and we're gonna make a nice
easy to break
quick shelter
for the night time
it's like a tent yeah
block that off block
block block block block block okay we're
to
block block all right we're safe
oh my sword out dang it whatever chill
witch
we're chill okay there we go now break
down all this wood that i do not want
placed here
look i already started on the walls
like a boss
yeah that's not gonna be where we want
our wood
yeah so we won't see the these in the uh
maybe i should make out a cobblestone
since just to have it a
stronger house i'll do that
in goblins don't you guys think a
cobblestone house looks good
i do
i like wood i'm so conflicted
i don't know if we have glass that is
good
oh now i slept here awesome i'll spawn
here if i die
we're not gonna need a glass back here
since it's not not really a good view no
no no
now what to do what to do
so i probably won't have outros and
intros private videos like i normally do
because i'm gonna
be recording for longer so don't look
for that
i'm gonna start breaking down these
trees probably end up burning a lot of
them
i really should collect the wood though
huh trying to think how i should do this
what everything normal i'm not good
so we're gonna want a double door
want
but it's worth it i want a double door
so one two three one two one
two three and then
one ah tray
two three
i'm gonna make a little taller than my
old house because my health house was
way too small
go fail i feel like i'm not going to be
using much of this class
so if i want a double door i'm just
going to go like that
don't i'll expand on this don't worry
don't worry guys
and so i can do two
giant windows yeah it's good
i'll fail boom boom
yeah that's good and should we have like
that
it's not gonna be very strong if i could
say a creeper blows up but
uh we're playing on hard so we're gonna
want iron doors
so that's a no-go
but for iron doors we need buttons and
pressure plates
so
what to do what to do
since like button that has to like be it
below since i can't place a button on
glass
damn there's a confusion on what i
should do
hmm
hmm what to do what to do guys what
should i do
i could
looks like let's get some torches up in
here
torches up in here
and some on the inside
i wonder what to do let's just break
this
oh i just need i didn't get the xp for
smelting it dang it whatever
i'll move you
boop i'll get you in here
can you fix that
uh i'll break this break this tree down
wow just happens
and an apple wow this tree is just
freaking giving me all the goods
now what should i do
you